30 seconds did you ever think you
make VI I know this
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giving values
contagious world of entrepreneurs we get
no value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm the I'm the
one episode 314 we have the great
Charlie Charlie Kirk in the house and by
the way let me tell you what this is a
special uh podcast because this may be
the last broadcast podcast he does in
his 20s because he's turning 30 this
week 30 I'm getting way too old for this
stuff actually old way too old for this
stuff I'm going to retire 30 this is it
for you it's been a good run yeah that
makes sense somehow I don't believe that
you got a lot more work to do you got a
lot of things to do and you're not the
type of guy that's going to slow down
but uh you know obviously we're sitting
here going through all the stories and
we wish we didn't have these stories to
go through we wish the stories were
slightly different but the world is a
mess today first we're dealing with
Ukraine and Russia last year the last 6
12 whatever the timeline's been uh we're
dealing with economy we're dealing with
interest rates we're dealing with people
defaulting on car payments we're dealing
with corporations defaulting on their
debt payments we're dealing with
unemployment right now concerning with
what's going to happen with that is that
going to move or is it not going to move
if it's not moving Jerome pal wants to
continue increasing interest rates
that's scary for some people people are
no longer buying houses y even with all
that stuff going on then all of a sudden
this happens this last week Hamas Israel
Palestine and protesting down the street
from here 300 people protesting down the
street from our office in Florida in
Florida to the point where the santis
had to come out and tweet about it the
governor had to come out and tweet about
it but anyways I'll pause it's great to
have you I know you're obviously
following the story very closely what's
on your mind what are you thinking
what's going on yeah I just want to
first for the audience to make sure
everyone's thinking about this clearly
this was not a typical military type
attack when Russia invaded Ukraine which
was bad they went after military targets
I mean some civilians get caught in the
crossfire but the targets were military
in nature this is completely different
this was Hamas that penetrated the
Border they did engage some IDF soldiers
and then they did a detour and went to
concerts in kutes women and children
this this is the closest to the
Holocaust that any of us have seen in
our life 1,200 Jews slaughtered in one
day and from paragliders and I mean you
see the concert videos these young
ladies are running through the fields
and they're mowing them down mercilessly
and now we know well over 15 Americans
are dead it might actually be more than
that now because the death the death
tally keeps on getting higher and higher
and I'll be honest Patrick you know the
Israel situation is important to talk
about geopolitically what's how American
passport holders American citizens have
been reacting here domestically has
really captured my attention what do you
mean by that well for example the
student body president at NYU Law sent
out a message the other day saying is
Israel brought this upon themselves 31
Harvard students said this is a great
thing right not students student
organizations that's correct that's
right and Columbia University something
very similar George Washington
University something very similar Cal
State Long Beach Cal State Long Beach
some of the student organizers Patrick
they were bringing out images of the
paraglider as if they said these are
Freedom Fighters these people are sick
there is no middle ground with this
there is no other side of the story this
is the mass murring of women and
children and so I I think that you know
we have to take a step back and ask
ourselves you know how do you get to a
place where that kind of moral toxin
becomes so infiltrated into your country
into a Zeitgeist into the narrative then
you have black lives matter Global
Network in Chicago they deleted this
tweet probably not because they don't
believe it but because quite honestly
they got such backlash where they also
had the paraglider where they said you
know a fight for justice somewhere is a
fight for justice anywhere so this is
this has been I'll be honest I do this
for a living I do 3 hours a radio day 3
hours a podcast this has been a very
heavy week I mean heavy morally heavy
geopolitically um and I I don't see it
getting better anytime soon the entire
region is blowing up it could turn into
a regional war and not to mention our
own country is collapsing in real time
so so I I don't I fully agree with you
if you want to show this Rob so the
audience can see this as well I'm sure
seen it all yeah they deleted it but
this has been all over the place why you
know what I love about this though let
me tell you what I love about this
because during times of Crisis everybody
reveals themselves on who they are great
you come out you show that and then all
of a sudden hey NBA how come you've been
quiet didn't you put BLM all over the
place hey hey NFL hey hey what happened
Apple hey all these other weren't you
guys all supportiv of this what do you
think about this do you support this
well no we don't support this all let's
just stay kind of quiet their PR guys
are saying what they're saying but you
know the question I got for you is the
following um obviously we live in
America and everybody that's listened to
this from all over the world whatever
country you're in your priority is where
you live it should be yes it's where
your kids are it's where your family is
you know your priority is the state you
live in your priori is our priority is
here the people that live in Israel
their priority is Israel everybody's
priorities where they live in the
concern here is Vinnie can you share
some of those numbers from October 2021
to October 2023 y who has cross the
southern border if you don't mind giving
some of that data all right so uh do you
guys know how many special interest
illegal aliens have been caugh yeah this
is it so and for for everybody that
doesn't know special interest alien is
anyone from countries that pose a
national security threat that might
support or shelter terrorism Customs and
Border Patrol have estimated that 1.5
million illegals entered the US without
being detected and no wonder why Charlie
because I feel like this is all a plan
um uh here are the numbers agents
recorded special interest aliens Syria
coming into the country from uh October
2021 to October 2023 Pat in 2 years um
Syria 538 Yemen 139 Iran 659 Iraq 123
Afghanistan
6,386 Lebanon 164 Egypt
3,153 Pakistan
1,613 turkey
3,830 and usbekistan
13, 624 and let's not forget Pat and
Charlie you know there's 200 the FBI
have caught ter on the terror watch list
200 that we caught let alone the ones
that we have no like we have no idea
about so then that goes to ask people's
the question Pat why why is the Border
why they let the Border wide open this
entire time that's exactly why the
freaking reason is and it's going to get
worse what do you mean by that's why the
reason is by Pat here's my thing for the
past couple years Charlie we all of us
have been watching Pat mayoras in front
of Congress and they're like from
everybody yelling at them like why why
is the Border why no answer he beats
around the bush he can't give a specific
answer it's almost as if Pat all these
people are in here right now to do
something crazy to us in this country
because as you know the Hamas leader but
why though I I think because one one of
them is to cause chaos Pat cuz guess
what election is coming up too what they
can't do pandemic again how you going to
keep everybody at home I this is
remember House of Cards season five
episode 7 they did a fake terrorist
thing at a polling thing nobody's going
to go if something happens at a poll
Center they're going to shut down guess
what who's going to go vote P you're
going to vote from your house why why
else is it a humanitarian thing you
think they care about Venezuelans and
Mexicans and people and by the way these
people that are coming in Charlie you
know how old these guy that's 18 to 35
they're military fighting age men Pat
and the UN is giving them cards Charlie
with money on it and a cell phone saying
hey go get an apartment and when we call
you that's right we like Vin VIN this
this is actually pretty shocking to me
because I I don't want to just gloss
over this all Vin like these are these
are people from the Middle East that
they've caught at the US border crossing
but that's that's just one year okay one
that's just in one year that's that
that's who we've caught not who's C away
and this is who's been caught meaning
they didn't catch everybody so why would
someone from Iran Iraq Afghanistan
Pakistan all these countries why would
they be coming through the southern
border let me stay on this series of
questions I'm asking here's where I'm
going with this okay so let's say
they're doing it intentionally let's
let's process that one who is there two
why are they doing it intentionally yeah
I think that I mean it's obviously
they're doing it intentionally and let's
just say the Democrat Party and moderate
Republicans they have different reasons
for it and the Democrat Party thinks
that they get more power politically if
they allow the third world to come into
the country they're not totally right
about that actually it turns out that
you know third world people that enter
America they have values that are
against white upper middle- class woke
liberalism but that don't take my word
for it look at the Castro Brothers the
Castro Brothers uh who you know one was
a mayor of San Antonio other one served
in the Obama Administration housing
Urban Development one of them ran the
Democrat National Committee there's a
clip that you could find on CBS Face the
Nation they have memory hold this clip
so if you if you find it Kudos on you
where they said um you know they were in
this interview and they said Hey in just
a couple years you're going to be
calling the electoral votes for Texas
because uh for Democrats because of how
many Hispanics are coming into Texas
these are two card carrying partisan
Democrats that are telling you that
Texas will become blue will become
Democrat
because they're allowing people from the
third world to come now mind you Patrick
what I just said I get attacked by the
media they say oh this is a great
replacement conspiracy theory and that
that that's what's called a thought
terminating cliche they say it to you so
you don't actually think about it but
why else would they keep the Border
completely wide open there is no border
right now and border patrol is not
deterring entry into the United States
they are facilitating entry into the
United States they are co-sponsoring it
I live in a border state we are
experiencing 5,000 day 5,000 a day and
border patrol is basically saying come
to us here's your court date here's your
piece of paper into the interior United
States you know see in a couple years
maybe and they don't show up for their
court date yeah right so there's two
aspects to this first is just the flow
of people that are coming that are going
to destabilize our social services that
look what's happening in New York right
they don't have the infrastructure to uh
support it the more immediate concern
and caution I have is sleeper cells in
the United States that are from
terrorist countries that could be
activated to do harm against the
homeless land and that's not
fearmongering the head of Hamas said
this tomorrow he's called for a look at
it own words M I want to make sure I'm
accurate no you're right KH M call for
international translated in eng can you
no but I I want to make sure I'm
accurate because I got attacked by the
media for you know fearmongering no
you're not you're actually right I I I
have it all right here his name is
Khaled mhal the he was Global day of
jihad tomorrow yeah he said show anger
especially on Friday in Muslim countries
also among Muslim dispo around the world
and he called Friday of Alaska flood he
said this will send a message of Rage to
Zionist to America he asked for
financial help from all Muslims around
the world to help their money and he
called it a financial Jihad he asked
Muslims to give the fighters of Gaza in
order to compensate them for Destruction
uh the more important thing this is
final words funds are important but
today we are asking for your blood and
souls to be sacrificed for Palestine so
I'm giving everybody a heads up and
that's why they' Always that's tomorrow
that's tomorrow it's Friday the 13th and
Charlie with everything that's going on
with the failure of security with a
message like that from this demon thank
God for our founding fathers for giving
us the Second Amendment thank you God
because guess what I dare when pops
off here Pat God you know I feel bad for
everybody that happened over there
nobody had guns for 3 to six hours
apparently the best military one of the
best ones in the world just disappeared
over here I'm proud of America cuz we
got guns come try that with us
let's stay on this let's stay on this
cuz I actually want to go a little bit
deeper okay so the the people
Texas we're going to turn it blue you
know the more immigrants we bring fine
totally get that strategically respect
it fine I totally understand what you're
doing to the left uh you want to turn
your state to be more blue cool do your
thing Texas has been an enemy for a long
time I get it however the the they
people okay not the lower level people
the they people the they people
typically have money the they people
typically want to control their wealth
these are the Puppet Masters these are
the guys that have the money that are
controlling why why would they be okay
with allowing 70,000 whatever the number
was to come through knowing these day
people are probably Legacy people who
have wives who have kids who have
grandkids why would they do that knowing
they could jeopardize the community
they're in the value of their property
the value of their company the value of
their business why would they do that
Alexander saniton wrote the gulag
archipelago which brought down the
Soviet Union and he said thanks to
ideology this all happened and I'm going
to give you an example and I'll tie it
together you can go to the George Soros
open Society Foundation website and just
show people he believes in an
ideological campaign that borders are
the worst thing ever Sovereign nations
are the problem George SOS is a devout
believer in that ideology and what has
been an eye opener for me Patrick and I
can use a couple examples reality is not
the ultimate verdict of how you act
ideology can actually be more more
critical in uh New York City a week and
a half ago a young lady was sitting on a
park bench with her boyfriend you might
have covered this story right we did
3:51 a.m. you know black guy comes by
slits the throat of the boyfriend she
doesn't even administer first aid that's
not the point it's very strange when the
police went to her she refused to give
the race of the attacker oh my God
because she did not want people to think
it was done for race wow I'll give you
another example I'll give you another
example a young lady was gang raped in
Germany by Arabs okay I'm not saying all
Arabs do it but unfortunately it's a
pattern that we're seeing spike in
Europe it's a thing Arab Muslims she
goes to the police and says I was gang
raped they said please describe your
attackers and she says it was six white
Germans Jesus so they go and try to find
six white Germans they fail they come
back and she admits oh actually it was
six Arab Muslims I didn't want to tell
you because I didn't want to increase
the amount of anti-immigrant fervor she
she protected her rapists because she
was taking ideology over reality Patrick
why why why why does Soros want the
borders open he's a devote to an
ideologic dare I say pseudo religion to
create the world into a different type
of place no borders no cash no property
you can call it Heaven on Earth Utopia
you can even call it etiz the escaton
that's like a real that's a religious
term that we're going to bring the we're
going to bring the Eternal promise of
paradise here Paradisio as Dante would
say and they want it now and they think
that the problem is Western Society the
problem is private property the problem
is America and if you look at through
that lens all of a sudden you say wow
Biden is not incompetent it's
intentional you destroy the dollar you
keep the Border open you weaken the
military it gets you closer to a One
World Government of which they are
bragging in the world economic Forum
Vision 2030 you'll own nothing you'll be
happy America will no longer be the
world's superpower anyway I don't mean
to let's let's still stay on this okay
for every out of the 900 billionaires
that we have in America for every one
Soros how many billionaires Power
Players are against it meaning do I
believe Soros has
another 20 buies that think can believe
what he believes in sure do I think he's
got another 50 sure I don't know what
the number is I don't think it's that
big of a number that you think it is but
I think he does have a group of people
he has a circle okay I'm with it I think
that's that's a smaller than 50 more
than 10 people let's say something like
that but the other guys are not with it
I I I don't see a Griffin being forward
I don't see schwarzman being forward I
don't see you know Buffett being forward
I don't see a musk being forward I don't
see even a Bezos being for I don't see a
lot of these bigger Power Players being
forward so musa's credit is fighting
against it uh Bezos is afraid uh his
ex-wife is for it McKenzie Bezos is
pumping billions of dollars into the
most radical leftwing causes you could
imagine I'll give you another name
that's not talked about a dayot to the
ideological agenda Loren pal jobs one of
the wealthiest women on the planet Steve
jobs' Widow $20 billion um she owns the
Atlantic magazine uh she also uh runs
something called the Emerson Collective
uh you could look at it she's one of the
biggest donors to that uh she she's an
ideological deot but Patrick I will
agree with you if you get a hundred
random billionaires in the country every
industry right Sports oil auto
manufacturing the problem is many of
them are cowards and that they do not
want to fight they would rather have
their business be protected they would
rather be able to have a backup business
is not being protected no but but
they're not fighting Patrick musk is
that's why musk is being criminally
investigated by the southern district of
New York for a house did you see this
story a glass house that is a warning
shot to musk to tell him the back off
and he doesn't to his credit musk is has
done such good for Humanity to to be
what Carnegie and rockerfeller and JP
Morgan used to be because we think so
negatively those people but they loved
America we have a different problem in
our country the powerful hate the
country that they got rich in it's very
bizarre and it's incredibly Insidious so
you think about it right the the if you
look at the elites you're always going
to have Elites right you're always going
to have a ruling class there's always
been one and you're NE this idea of
egalitarianism that everyone's going to
be equal is garbage we should then argue
for better Elites Elites that want to
Steward the country and care about the
middle class not Elites that are worried
about executing a cultural and political
Blitz C on the fabric of the greatest
nation ever to exist in the history of
the world and it doesn't take a lot of
them Patrick you get a Soros you get a
loren pal jobs another name for you Reed
Hoffman another name for you Mark
bennyhoff bennyhoff is a legit Marxist
like that guy is to the left of Stalin
he he bought he bought Time Magazine
he's a sales force he's a Salesforce
these are just off the top of my head
right so you get so you get Len pal jobs
you get bennyhoff right you get M
McKenzie Bezos you get Soros you're
talking about siries capital in addition
to the Ford Foundation the MacArthur
Foundation The Bill Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation
and in addition to the institutional
capture and control and then you get
some people that quietly like I think I
agree I think Jeff Bezos is probably in
private more libertarian than he is
liberal based on everyone I know that
knows him but he he wants to play like
rockets in space and he owns the
Washington Post he doesn't seem like
someone who's going to fight billionaire
tyranny instead he's going to do what
most people do when Evil's on the March
nothing Pat can I ask you a question
like if you're we're talking about these
massive entrepreneur rurs that have
built Billion Dollar Plus companies
correct okay built on the basic premise
of free market capitalism
entrepreneurship building these types of
companies how does someone like that who
build something that understands what it
means to create jobs and and and build
companies how do they go so far left to
this Marxist ideology you called it um
egalitarianism how like you you
interviewed the one guy that wanted to
bump up everybody's pay in the company
to $70,000 it was sort of contentious
price Dan price yeah Dan price exactly
how do you go from building such a
massive company but built on the
principles of what America's founded on
on capitalism free enterprise the free
market and they go so far left how does
that happen well I mean I'm really
trying to process this it's either
second generation money so meaning you
didn't earn it because if you earned it
it's a different mindset but many of
these guys earned it okay Jobs's wife
got it okay Melinda Gates fine Mackenzie
Bezos mck B totally get it those three
totally get it you didn't do like in our
community I'll walk by and you know I'll
see some of the people that you know or
maybe they married they're the second or
third wife of a guy after he made the
money and then the first wife's no
longer in the picture well the first
wife was probably but then he go like
well you know you see when they talk to
them they just look down at you
sometimes like okay very weird and some
are very friendly right you process both
of these on how it is and then you you
go and you ask another question and you
say okay so maybe someone's got
something on these guys maybe they're
scared of somebody maybe they're
frightened of somebody maybe somebody
even more powerful than them has got you
know them under control for whatever
reason but the more and more and more
you go deeper you're like dude this is
going to eventually end up hurting you
like in what way do you think this is
going to favor you like actually what do
you think's going to happen I understand
somebody like for example proxy wars
okay I understand a proxy war why do I
understand a proxy war to me you know
what a proxy war is oh Adam you won't
believe what Vinnie said to you Vinnie
you won believe what Adam said to you
and I'll watch you guys fight M okay
that's a proxy war right that's that's
instigating yeah shut up Adam that's
instigating to see that so maybe you do
that to create division in the enemy's
house mhm okay deceptive yes dark for
sure sunu yeah totally is but you know
what I get it because at least it's what
someone else's house yeah yeah but
imagine
you pin your own kids against each other
and and you
intentionally you know get the front
security let's just say you're live in a
gated community to get him to get fired
and you replace him with sloppy people
that are 82y old security you know how
you go to a hotel they got these 82y old
security people they hire and you're
like who's this guy going to stop right
this guy's going to stop anybody no then
you allow people to come into your
community for what for them to invade
your house and hurt your own kid that's
the part where there's a disconect that
doesn't make sense so some of them are
insulated I mean they have priced out
the real estate market in their home of
Sun Valley Aspen Kenny bunkport they are
legitimately isolated from any of the
consequences of their political
decisions right I mean if you go to
Aspen you would think that that you know
like we have solved every problem right
I mean if you go to Aspen in July right
everyone is like fit and trim there's
there's not like a BMI over like 35
right I was literally there in July am
right this freaking par all of a sudden
you're like why can't we have world
peace and is there a you know what
no it's it's it's almost like you just
like when you're completely isolated and
you're not around any of this well not
only that when you are surrounded by
very successful good-looking attractive
high IQ people that's not number one
Patrick so they really they they are not
in compon they are not in you know a
neighborhood that is going to be overrun
they're not in the real Grand Valley
they're not in you know cville Texas
that's going to be overrun but there's
another part to this though and some of
the billionaires look at themselves
there's two categories that I want to
mention that we haven't they look at
themselves as Masters of the Universe
and these are usually tech people this
is Larry pagee this is Sergey Brin this
is Mark Zuckerberg I get those guys okay
that for them they really think they can
reconfigure Society through AI
technocracy almost like a highly
sophisticated oligarchy because they
think that the problem is that we
haven't had smart enough people in
charge almost ruled by committee and I
want to be in charge of that committee
okay but the second part Patrick is that
some of these guys will do whatever it
takes so that they are favored by The
pullit Bureau they'll give any amount of
money they really don't have any
ideological spin either way they just
want to be on the winning team if the
right wing was ascendant in the country
some of these guys would be giving money
to like pro-life clinics and churches
they some of these guys just go with the
wind they want to be protect by the
regime they don't really believe
anything dude let me let me let me tell
you man I mean uh uh U okay go let's
play the dark game Let's Play Let's Go
dark okay all right
so um I'm on a flight yesterday and my
pilot is the pilot I like you you
actually met this
pilot he the pilot
so I see him I said how you doing not
good I said okay I said uh what do you
think about what's going on last time he
was with us when we went to Milwaukee
you know I I like him yeah so so how you
doing obviously not good family how's
family not good family in Israel how
about this how about that how about this
anyways I can't tell you everything we
talked about because I found out who he
is and what he did his job in Israel
very interesting very serious
guy he says to me says you know what
though the Israelis Community right now
is very happy with Joe Biden I said
really tell me why he says because he's
uh he's got our back and he's shown so
many great
uh things he's doing you know blinkin is
going there and he want to shook hands
with Netanyahu and you know they're
showing support and they're with us and
they're saying pro Israel and they're
saying this and even Jean Pierre you
know came out and said a couple words
the squad she went after the squad
that's right which is kind of weird
right crazy so okay so you're sitting
there you're like you know maybe the
center people are like okay these guys
sound normal right okay so let's play
Dark did you need something like this
for you to create a war to the point
where the reelection percentage of a
president goes so high when there's a
war so you can get reelected maybe is it
because the amount of chaos you learned
in 2020 elections was so chaotic so it
increases the chance of you being able
to win another election because the more
chaotic it was you can tell people what
we're going to be doing and they're
already accustomed to it maybe they'll
be more open-minded to it maybe is it is
it because maybe even on the other side
for me that I think about Netanyahu and
Israel first of all who has the best
secret intelligence in the world mad mad
you mean to tell me no you you mean to
tell me these guys have been that lowkey
underground for a year built a city like
the one in Israel and they trained their
guys to go in and how to break into
homes and how to take people hostage and
you're telling me you didn't know
seriously and Egypt comes out by the way
the story came out it's like well you
know we told them we warned them that
something was taking place another story
came out about Egypt R if you tell me
what page it's on then they said they
didn't they're going back and forth yeah
they're saying they you're like so so
make up your mind did you know or did
you not know so what is really going on
so then I go later deeper and I I'll
turn it over to you is okay did did
Israel almost you know because I'm
talking to this other guy and he says I
said you realize what happened in 2014
he says yeah I said 2014 when they you
know the the three girls were kidnapped
and then you know whatever happened
raped travesty and then Israel comes
back and kills 2,000 people P to he said
it should have been
20,000 it should have been 200,000 so I
said where are you going with this he
says well listen here's what I'd like to
see happen in Israel what's that only
Jews live in Israel nobody else we don't
need to coexist it's just not going to
work out is this a way for netanyahu's
legacy to be he eliminated H Hamas is
this his way for saying now I got the
world I got the card I got the you know
get out of jail card for me to go
straight up 100,000 on the blockade of
Gaza Strip 300,000 reservist you put up
there now we're going to go groundwork
we're going all freaking out because the
world gave us the permission to do so is
that what it is I don't know I just keep
continuing to have a lot of questions
the more I think about it
because so these guys are coming up so
what are we going to have another 911
and and they're going to come and do
what they're going to go into your
community what are you going to Target
next where are you going to go next
what's what's going to happen next oh
can we it's not a big deal it's never
never happen again well that's what we
thought it was never going to happen
9/11 before 9/11 happened nobody thought
911 was going to happen so I I I just
have way too many questions that makes
me think about what the motives are and
if we go dark I put all those things out
there yeah how did how did these guys
not know this was taking place so I've
been Israel many times the whole country
is a fortress when I first heard this
story I still have the same gut instinct
that I did initially I find this very
hard to believe I've been to that Gaza
border you cannot go 10 ft without
running into a 19-year-old with an AR-15
or an automatic machine gun that an IDF
Soldier right the whole country is
surveilled and so so let me let me just
kind of go through this we don't talk
about Israeli politics very often and
most Americans don't know this the last
nine months Israel was on the brink of
Civil War it's not an exaggeration this
judicial stuff there were there were
hundreds of thousands of Israelis taking
to the streets because BB Netanyahu is
basically redefining the Israeli
Constitution that's not an EXA
exaggeration right he said the judicial
branch has too much power there were
protests planned this week against
Netanyahu where they anticipated tens of
thousands of people to take to the
streets that's all gone Patrick
Netanyahu now has an emergency
government and a mandate to lead I'm not
I'm not willing to say to go so far that
saying that Netanyahu knew or there is
intelligence here but I think some
questions need to be asked was there a
stand down
order was there a standown
order six hours I don't believe it
Israel's the side of new size of New
Jersey when I took a helicopter ride
from Jerusalem to the Gaza border it's
45 minutes wow six hours they're live
streaming the killing of Jews was did
somebody in the government say stand
down that is a legitimate nonc
conspiracy question the whole country is
the IDF the whole country is yeah and
you're trying to tell me that they're
going to concerts and kutzas and schools
and by reports 6 hours let's say it's
three
hours that's
suspect go ahead Rob it's also not like
a right winged uh reporting this is from
The New York Times the long wait for
help as mass unfolds in Israel I can't
think of a more liberal news Outlet than
the New York Times and and but by the
way I I'm actually very pro-israel so
let me be very I mean so I'm not exact I
think we all are no no I just want to
make sure my position is clear here but
I would so Patrick there are other
explanations it's possible that the
Netanyahu government was double crossed
by bad agents okay that's dark but it's
not as dark as what we're talking about
okay another aspect is that Netanyahu
might have traders in his government
like legitimate traders that have
infiltrated I was texting with some
senior people in the IDF and they said
Charlie can't say too much but let's
just say the same problem you have with
the left in America we have here in
Israel there's something to think about
just something to think about right is
that maybe there are some people within
those Intel agencies that are aren't as
sympathetic or maybe Patrick maybe they
might have gotten a tip they might have
gotten Whispers but no one thought it
would be 1,200 Jews dead that's a
potential right because here here's the
here's the essence of it the essence is
this this is the closest thing to the
Holocaust that any of us have lived
through but the fact is now BB and the
Israeli hard-right government has a
mandate I gotta be careful the way I say
this to they're going to try to
ethnically cleanse Gaza yep I mean that
that's and I don't use that term lightly
okay they're talking about basically
removing 2.5 million people from there
okay and honestly they have a mandate to
go seek Justice and revenge they do
there is they this idea that they need
to have a TR truce or a peace treaty
that's morally crap after you see women
and children be burned alived and
dragged to the streets but there are
some serious questions here Patrick and
let me tell you my pattern recognition
over the last five years has become
pretty sharp coid Maui fires you know
Epstein when I see a story and it
doesn't
click we're our guts are usually
right yeah this one's this one's very
weird can I um comment on the you know
when you when you use the term ethnic
cleansing that will you know make the on
the Backus no I'm not I'm just saying
that term uh actually did some research
specifically on that
because that is a very slippery slope
and if you actually want to talk about
what
Jews and even Christians uh should be
most fearful of Muslims as well is the
concept of ethnic okay I just want to be
very Sor sorry to interrupt I'm saying
that's what they're going to be accused
of correct but if there are some people
in public life in Israel
that Patrick what did your pilot guy say
I want only Jews in Israel right okay
that that is a form of ethnically
cleansing because 20% of Israel is Arab
mus correct 20% and people don't don't
know that and I've been to Israel
several times I was there a few months
ago and I saw the protests yes you know
you don't have to be
uh uh expert at Israeli politics to
understand the divisiveness of politics
especially in America we understand like
Republicans Democrats blacks white
whatever it is Sim similar in Israel
there's the liberal faction mostly based
in Tel Aviv and more the conservative
faction in in Jerusalem and throughout
the country and obviously the more
Orthodox you are the more you're um
inclined to be more right-wing thinking
um but I think Civil War is a little
premature but there is Major contention
going on there the country was was was
at a fissure point right it was it was
splitting no doubt just like there was
calls for potential Civil War here I I I
I I I sort of think that's a little
aggressive but you would agree it was
hot the country was hot doubt just like
the BLM riots here no no it it it was
not a time for Unity in Israel the the
thing that I think to just to think
about when you talk about not I'm not
saying you're accusing anything you just
use the term so the concept ethnic
lesing is the biggest
fear of the Jewish people okay it's the
whole reason that Israel was founded
because of the ethnic cleansing that
occurred throughout Europe for Millennia
right obviously culminating with World
War II but there's no doubt that Hamas
that Israel could wipe out Gaza at any
given point but they do not want to
participate in ethnic cleansing now they
would love to annihilate the terrorists
but if you actually talk about what's
going around the world today and this is
what Israel needs to kind of take note
of that's what I was talking about
Patrick I'm sorry to interrupt this is a
protest in the summer this every day
there were people in the streets saw
July of the country was separating it
this is such a hotbed issue right now
but if you talk about ethnic cleansing
look at what's going on in azaran and
Armenia P something that that 11,000
Armenian Christian nobody's talking
about that we've seen over the last
couple decades uh you know what happened
in Bosnia they were they were Bosnian
Christians were killing Muslims we've
seen what's going on in Myanmar nobody
talks about that okay uh Christians are
actually there's an article right here
from the KO Institute who are the most
persecuted people in the world well it's
actually Christians you've probably done
your research on this I I talk about it
all the time you go to Afghanistan you
go to Iraq you go to Iran you go to
China you go to Nigeria they're killing
Christians here it is right here from
the KO Institute right okay so the the
the whole concept of ethnic cleansing I
think temperatures need to go down
because it's it it's not egalitarian
people are killing people for multiple
reasons and here's Israel's difficulty
is that Hamas they build their
headquarters under hospitals correct
they use human as human Shields and so
civilians are going to die and that is a
tragedy and Hamas brought this upon
themselves my wish my plead to Israel is
be precise be focused in your
retaliation you have a moral right to go
and seek the blood of the people that
did this what I I think would be bad for
Israel and I have a heart for Israel I I
I can't tell you what it did it it made
me a stronger Christian a way I can't
even tell you right be able to see where
our Lord rose from the dead my heart for
Israel is that they don't overreact that
and I and Patrick you hear what I'm
saying here right I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
that that's my concern because if they
do uh again if they do overreact I'm
more coming from a place of thinking
this was intentional if they don't
overreact then this wasn't intentional
meaning if all of a sudden you see an
allout Annihilation what do you mean by
intentional that they knew it was going
to happen that that no when you're
asking about the stand down 6 hours and
3 hours why did you what are you getting
so we're on the same pict fa saying I
just wanted to make sure I understood if
there is a major attack it was
intentional if there's a major attack
and by the
way um the the number in the last
however many years the big the biggest
number they have is 2,000 right
Palestinians that died that's the
biggest number they've had and in Gaza
if you look at the Gaza Strip on if you
can pull up the map so you can kind of
show Gaza Strip the West Bank and you
know where
coming from Lebanon yeah but but in one
in West Bank it's a different story
because in West Bank at least you know
42% of Palestinians there support Hamas
but in Gaza it's 58% Hamas really isn't
in those regions yeah it really is not
in those regions so this is this is Gaza
Strip you know all the way to the left
can I emphasize though look at the
cameras The Radars Patrick not only did
they go in say but let hear me out here
not only did they go into Israel they
got out of Israel with hostages yeah 100
hostages so you would think let let me
just hear me out there's a penetration
of your border wall okay that you guard
on a holy day the 50e anniversary of the
yapor war and you would think hey let's
they're going to come back let's make
sure that doesn't happen let's mobilize
some forces and
it it is it is not quite but it is close
to the North Korean demilitarizing
what's weird about what you're saying
that get that gets even more credibility
is you're a pro-israel guy no that that
I want to be very clear no fully I know
that so I want to make sure the audience
knows this so for you to question that
and for me to question I'm like sitting
here saying how did you not know this
was taking place but again going back to
it if Okay so let's go let's go to a
different uh uh uh angle here okay
so
um many times when crisis happens we we
sit oh my gosh we immediately go to
World War III like we have a yearning
for you know Armageddon there's almost a
little bit of a yearning people have for
oh my God what would a civil war really
look like bro that's like crazy I get to
take a month off from work like sh you
said and play cards all day I have all
these guns I want to use them these are
people that have never gone to a country
that's at war or never experienced war
no it's the worst thing human being
trust me like I posted a picture the
other day my sister texted me poette I'm
like you know you how always talk about
putting the you know tapes on the
Windows yeah I I don't know if you saw
that picture it's like that picture was
po like look at this picture what do you
see unique in this picture I said it's
pretty cool you and I when we were kids
he says no no look at the glass I'm like
oh just in case they this is the
tapes this is me and Iran with my sister
when we would get bombed one day we got
bombed 167 times okay we my dad would
put tape so the window wouldn't explode
on our faces cuz that's our bedroom like
I'm on I'm on this side is the uh uh is
the and then the other side is our rooms
and he's like hey if something happens
so you look at these stories they like
yeah I mean kids are going through but
go go a little bit deeper with this
let's go a little bit deep let's let's
go next step here with this okay what
what is truly the worst case that's
going to happen we have a Fascination
and an obsession with market crash
collapse war Civil War this is the last
election this is the most important
election of all time I'm telling you or
else we're going to lose America right
of course all of these things is a we of
controlling fear urgency I get it
there's a certain element of you know
motives behind it that that's effective
but how ugly you think this actually can
get like the domino effect if this
happens these guys react and if these
guys react these guys have to react that
Meme where it like all starts with you
know a mean tweet and it ends in nuclear
war you ever see that me domino effect
yes you know which one I'm talking about
sorry D interrupt yeah so what do you
how ugly can well I mean look here so
let me also make sure I criticize both
sides okay so I'm going to criticize the
people that you know do the paragliding
and it's sick lindsy Graham is an
irresponsible respons lawmaker what for
what he's saying bombing Iranian oil
Depot this thing could get wildly out of
control very very quickly the last thing
America needs is a kinetic war against
Iran an 87 million person country that
has a pretty Fierce fighting Spirit a
country that's five times the size of
Iraq five times side of Iraq we're going
to go start bombing oil Depot yeah that
could get Russia further involved China
involved yeah look the quote unquote
Armageddon situation is that for Israel
the Armageddon situation is that they
overreact so much that they lose their
Arab neutrality right now they have
neutrality with Egypt if they overreact
they could lose that they have warm
conversations I won't say a peace deal
yet with Saudi Arabia they could lose
that Jordan plays ball because America
demands they play ball they could lose
that Syria Bashar al-assad he acts as if
it doesn't exist but that could change
in a moment's notice right Lebanon via
Hezbollah is already there they could be
all of a sudden dealing with a 15
country invasion of isra can they handle
that they have in the past I mean the
The Six Day War the yam kapor War the
yam kapor War for example they were
invaded from every direction at the the
balfor dec declaration when they were
became a country in 1948 every Arab
country declared war on them and then
they were they almost lost the country
and to their credit they held it off and
they earned the right to be Israel but I
don't know what that looks like no one
does and you're talking about countries
that have some form of nuclear weaponry
as well Saudi Arabia doesn't have a
total nuclear developed bomb but they
you know they have some sophistication
far more than Iran but yeah look I mean
I I'm not an alarmist but if we take the
path of Nikki Haley and Lindsey Graham
like we're dramatically increasing the
chances of a World War can we stay right
there on the Iran situation obviously
this is very close to home lunatic wants
it's a pbd uh that picture I think says
a thousand words the the tape on the
Windows you're used to this when you've
seen bombings like this you've seen
death like this you wish this upon
nobody but the biggest question is like
you know we're so focused on what's
going on in Russia Ukraine granted
obviously the big picture I think we can
all agree is what's going on with China
right that's the big picture here but
you know in this region the tip of the
spear with all these issues is Iran so
as much as Lindsey Graham sounds uh like
a lunatic like like a like a wild man
War Maring Wildman John Bolton esque
type person they're the same person he
is at least bringing up the fact that
Iran needs to be deal with at the heels
of all this what's going on and you you
bring up like what you know so yeah
that's important the the next five moves
of Israel is there there at the final
Innings of this deal with Saudi Arabia
obviously Saudi Arabia and Iran are
enemies Shia Sunni irreconcilable right
so what must be done with Iran at this
point because to be to be clear they're
the ones that fund Hamas they're the
ones that on Hezbollah they're the
greatest exporter of terrorism around
the world
to to America after we get them6 billion
what do we do there the first thing is
we must remember that we the American
government are the reason why Iran is
radical we did this they had a
democratically elected leader that we
did not like I remember I believe his
name was mosag mosad yeah right mosad
yeah mosad thank you and we didn't like
him because he wanted to nationalize the
oil specifically the Brits didn't like
it this what year was this PB okay got
you this is before the show yes he he
was he was very popular and look right
there even even even in Wikipedia 1953
Iranian CET aided by intelligence
agencies of the UK and United States
weird got it okay so then we put the Sha
back in if my memory serves me correctly
who was sick and unpopular meaning he
was actually suffering physically sick
and we paved the way for the most
radical elements of Islam from a country
that Patrick you know it better than I
do the Persian people are the most
entrepreneurial they're some of the
smartest people that have really been
living under radical Islamic captivity
for many decades why am I bringing this
up sometimes your intervention can make
things far far worse sometimes
intervention is moral and necessary our
intervention in World War II in Europe
was moral and necessary so what to do
well I think Joe Biden should definitely
not give them $6 billion dollar I think
that's a good start I think that
sanctions is probably appropriate but I
also think that we have to be really
clear that
Iran is an enemy of the United States
but it pales in comparison to the
immediate and the pernicious and the
existential threat that the Chinese
Communist parties poses to America and I
don't want to see us get into the
Lindsey Graham dream world that Iran is
somehow murdering Americans they are
financing Terror they're chanting death
to America but China right now is
actively creating fenel that comes into
our country that kills over 100,000
people not everyone fentol but drug
overdoses yes over majority of the
100,000
what I'm getting at is I as a millennial
turning 30 know nothing but middle
Easter no wind War quagar right yep and
I am cynical and I'm very I think it's
my moral responsibility and my public
role as a commentator to slow down the
chatter anytime we're talking about
accelerating us closer to another
conflict in the Middle East because we
did it in Iraq I think it was a mistake
we spent trillions of dollars and we
lost precious American lives led to the
LED to Isis and you want the thought
crime honestly Saddam Hussein kept a lot
of the terrorists in check yep scared of
he was a bad guy but he wasn't the worst
guy and I think the same thing
Afghanistan so what do we do I think
first we have to calm down the
neoconservatives that are bloodthirsty
and want war more than they want what's
best for America yeah you know you know
what is uh this is this is
actually I think it's going to be a
filtering by the way I don't know if
this video is recent or we we shared it
the other day or it's right after they
killed gamman I don't know exactly the
date of this video so just kind of
verify when this video was what does it
say right there this video was from 3
years AG okay yeah this is when we
killed Kasam but attitude hasn't
changed opinions have changed
dramatically you you under under shot
thing you talk about with mad mosad was
a guy that came in who was the modern
day Bernie Sanders he want to
nationalize everything he wanted to
nationalize everything he wanted to you
know he you know nationalize everything
and then the Sha comes in the Sha comes
back comes back modernizes the whole
thing education improves women finally
have no longer you know age of marriage
for girls are no longer 8 years old or
13 years old he raised it to I think
whatever it was 15 years old and then
women can actually go become lawyers and
go to school education for women change
then what happened in the Middle East
when Iran was ran by him uh R pavi the
Sha is conflict in the Middle East was
less okay because now it was Iran who
had a good relationship with us for the
most part except when there was
Democratic president there was issues
but for the most part they had a good
relation with us and he had his 25-year
contract he wrote the the if you can go
to 1954 Iran oil deal it was a 1954 the
deal was coming up till
1979 uh uhum or something so it's called
the Consortium agreement of 1954 this
was a deal they did yeah British
Petroleum yeah this was a deal they did
that was a 25-year deal this is what's
so interesting about it watch this 195
so the provided Western oil companies
with 50% ownership of Iranian oil
production after its ratification in
1954 expiring what year
1979 so the the the PM I think the
leaders of UK US I want to say France
and one other country met in south or
Central America to talk about how to
prevent this
25-year contract from coming up because
the shot was going to go away from the
50% deal that's right and he was going
to rule the world he was going to become
so powerful 1979 is when it expires
guess when the Sha Sha expired 1979
maybe a little bit of a strange timing
on what they did with this year and then
comes Ki comes Hezbollah comes the 3,000
political prisoners cuz Jimmy Carter is
talking about human rights they're freed
a lot of them ended up becoming the Isis
the Hezbollah the two-day party the
Communist who ended up doing 911 so and
and Carter was pushing this with them
the similar thing that he did with Cubo
as well was like hey you need to free
it's not fair for what you're doing with
your people human rights he says no
problem here's 125,000 people I'm
releasing from Cuba to us and who did he
release political all those guys I'm
just a political Refugee I'm a political
prisoner right is what I am and Bo
unemployment unemployment in Miami goes
up to 50% but I understand what you're
saying with the Iran situation and
what's going to happen there so let me
let me bring you back to a different
thing if you got one last thought about
this I want to I don't want to just the
Iran thing is so fascinating to me
because I think they are the tip of the
Spear of what's going going on in the
Middle East and then who are they funded
by China what was the amount of money
that they gave them $400 billion million
so here's my question to you 25 years
okay just to kind of emphasize this if
you're a consultant or the uh National
Security adviser to whether it's Donald
Trump or Joe Biden or whoever it is you
pbd how do you deal with Iran do you
pull out of the nuclear deal entirely
like Trump did you get back into the
nuclear deal do you give them any money
whatsoever $6 billion for the hostages
how do you deal with Iran what do you do
yeah I think Trump had it right which
remember there was clamoring for Trump
to go to war against Iran and strike and
he resisted that the same time he was
tough and very firm where he you know
canceled the Iran deal went after
Soloman but you have to have your
priorities what is best for America
right war with Iran is not what is best
for America there's some other facts
about Iran that are important though I
think the Iran situation solves itself
over a period of time I believe 50% of
their population under under the age of
35 we can fact check it they have one of
the youngest populations on the planet
and we could fact check it it might it
might not be that extreme um but you
have a very very radical government the
people of Iran are incredibly talented
they're entrepreneurial they're
industrious and I I I'm actually more
bullish on the future of Iran if you can
liberate them from the Captivity that
they're under here you do that is my
point I you saw what happened last year
with the girls that's that's what's one
of the youngest we saw what happened
with when a girl took off her job she
was killed beaten the women have no
rights there the answer is it shouldn't
be a top priority of the American
government because we have so many
problems here to execute a CIA Cuda in
another country you have to put
sanctions on you have to put them in
check you have to try to in my personal
opinion allow Israel to seek Justice at
the same time you cannot allow this to
turn into an a regional broader War you
know why because the adult America is
going to have to come clean it up that's
why if we allow if we just kind of say
oh it doesn't that this thing turns into
a regional conflict we're going to have
more troops on the ground and we're
going to have to go clean up this mess
As Trump calls it in the region of sand
and death while our own country is
disintegrating and collapsing but look
there's a lot of other technical things
you could do to Iran right you can you
can prevent them access to European
markets which Joe Biden hasn't done
right they go and Shop in Paris and
London all the time you cut that crap
off right just like lifestyle stuff that
you could easily do you cut off student
visas right from from certain Iranian
expats you can put extra sanctions on
there's a lot of other tools you can do
um and the number one thing you can do
is you drill baby drill here
domestically and you weaken Iran's
energy hedge of money basically if you
increase the oil supply which Donald
Trump had us energy independent and
exporting more oil than we were
importing you significantly weaken Iran
and you you weaken Russia too if that
actually if you care about that right
the more you explore for oil in the
American Homeland um the weaker these
governments that are reliant on the
Petro dollar become what would you add
to that pbd I think he said he said
everything uh and more than what I would
have said uh look here's here's
interesting I'll transition it kind of
Mak sense to what you want to say the
Nero yesterday came out and ripped
Donald Trump again oh God and he says
Trump is evil he wrote out a whole thing
in in a speech want to be tough guy with
no morals or eth let me let me just read
this to you and I'll give you my
thoughts on this uh so Theo keep going a
little lower the entire speech is at the
bottom go lower lower lower lower you'll
see it when it's there right this
article three years ago he does this
every six months but here's the thing
though here's the thing though okay uh
I'm sorry I couldn't be with you today a
few days ago I came down with a heavy
cold D okay great I'm with you in spirit
I'm watching it's okay go I've spent a
lot of time studying bad men I've
examined their characteristics their
mannerisms the utter uh banality of
their cruelty yet there's something
different about Donald Trump when I look
at him I don't see a bad man truly I see
an evil one over the years I've met many
gangsters here and there this guy tries
to be one but he can't quite pull it off
there's such a thing as
honor among Thieves yet even criminals
usually have a sense of right and wrong
whether they do the right think or not
is a different story but they have a
moral code however warped Trump does not
he's a wannabe tough guy with no morals
or ethics no sense of right or wrong no
regard for anyone but himself not the
people he's supposed to lead or protect
not the people he does business with not
the people who follow him blindly and
loyally not even the people who consider
themselves as friends he has contempt
for all of them we New Yorkers got to
know him over the years that he was
poisoned the atmosphere literal ego we
knew first stand who he was we tried to
warn you in 2016 the repercussions
tribul 2020 okay the man who was
supposed to protect this country put in
Peril but of his recklessness impul was
an act of okay no mistake about it they
twice impeach four time indied Trump is
still a fool but we can't let our fellow
Americans ride him off evil thrives in a
shadow of dismissive mockery which is
why we must take the danger of Donald
Trump seriously so today we issue
another warning okay fantastic J from
this place where Abraham Lincoln spoke
right there in Beating Heart of New York
to the rest of America this is our last
chance democracy won't survive the
return of a wannabe dictator and it
won't become over anyways he keeps going
this like Chad
gbt but this is the point I want to make
to what he says okay great got it you
said this a few years at shrug that just
keeps going you know what he you know
what he made me think about this is what
he made me think about that that that
Trump is a gangster okay no problem who
the hell chooses to become a president
one of two people okay either somebody
who is a gangster or somebody who's
controlled by gangsters that don't have
a face to him which one would you rather
have so is Biden a gangster no he's just
a face gangsters are controlling what he
does he's a face is Trump a gangster
he's a gangster yep is Reagan a gangster
he's a gangster is Kennedy a gangster
he's a gangster is Obama a gangster he's
not a gangster he's controlled by by
other people we can keep going on and on
about all these gangsters okay no
problem so I've actually spent time with
gangsters and like real gangsters couple
like any one of them that's living I
pretty much have them on the podcast and
we've spent time with them okay we've
had conversations on camera off
camera and here's what I will say about
the history of the mob whenever the boss
was feared people weren't going killing
each other it's just how it was in New
York whenever the boss was weak guess
what people were doing going whacking
each other why because the was was not
somebody that you feared at that level
where he's going to come back and do
anything to you okay it was like don't
do it again Adam that's not cool right
versus hey you take the other made man
out or you put your hand on another
here's what's going to happen to you
right there was a certain element of
fear there's three things that a great
leader has to have fear you have to be
feared now especially when you're
running the most powerful country in the
world that's the hated and the loved and
the admired all three you got to be
feared you got to be respected and if
desert the last one is Desert if you can
be liked even better Reagan was liked
Trump's not liked okay let's just say
amongst some of these other guys fear
respect is necessary Trump was feared
and he was respected and he walked
around love him or hate him we didn't
have wars so going back to what you're
asking about Iran what he would do
here's what he would be doing there's no
6-hour standown or three- hour Stand
Down
here's what we're doing he's doing a uh
what do you call it a press conference
going out here's what we're going to do
here here's what we're remember that one
time when he he says uh Abu bakar what
was his name AB baddy baddy he cried
like he said and you're like who uses
these words right he was begging it was
it was such a can you pull up this video
clip if you have it obviously it it's
like a it's almost like out of a movie
one day our kids are going to watch this
movie about Trump and they're going to
say he would never say such a thing no
no son go watch the real clip he
actually said that Dad a president would
never say something like that but you
know what he did so to me this is the
element where I have a hard time sitting
here saying yeah none of this stuff is
on Biden in the US I'm sorry nobody
fears or respects or likes Biden so
guess what all the gangsters out there
are saying dude go and get everything
you want you know hey California they
say what you can go rob CVS or whatever
all these
st500 for it man go guys go we don't
care we're okay with it nome's more
worried about Skittles than fentol the
other day you know this guy spending
more time talking about skill go for it
so if if if you know Biden is a governor
of the world let's just say he's the
president now the Free World everybody
else is saying if there's ever been time
to go rob and take whatever you want
right now is the time to do cuz we have
no clue who the hell is coming next so
yeah theno as much as I love you your
movies your work you're an incredible
actor dude you are so at this point off
Bas it's not even funny how much anger
and hate you have towards this guy and I
would love to see you actually sell Rin
and bashing Trump why don't you flip it
on us dairo and sell us Biden go ahead
sell it to us write the same kind of a
novel you just wrote but sell Biden sell
us how amazing the economy is sell us
how peaceful the world is right now sell
us how everybody is so comfortable with
their jobs their houses their mortgage
rates sell us all of that stuff how
phenomenal he's doing you can Trash
Trump all you want he ain't the
President Biden's your president what
has Biden done why don't you do it I'd
love to see the ne sell Biden I don't
know if he can do it maybe what maybe
that's why he doesn't do it it's easy to
trash Trump than to go after selling us
how incredible of a job Biden's done
numbers came out the other day I think
it's the lowest um approval rating
approval rating that just came out about
Biden so what what are your thoughts
when you hear dairo on some of these
guys giving the giving us a lecture here
on who Trump is well first of all you
know you're makavelli so uh one of the
most important books ever written really
started the enlightenment is the prince
by makavelli um and we use makavelli as
a pejorative right oh makavelli and we
don't quite understand the Brilliance of
the Insight of makavelli makavelli was
actually applying for a job that's what
the prince was to the medich family uh
he wrote a series of letters and he was
like hey hire me as your political
consultant basically your political
adviser um and what Maki really wrote is
yes I mean there's a couple things ends
just by the means but that's such a
small like portion it really is it is
the most complete to date comprehensive
picture of how to rule justly how to
establish order and how to have
different tribes and factions and sects
be able to understand hierarchy have you
be respected use fear as a weapon as a
tool um and he did it in such a profound
way that I mean this guy knew his
Classics he knew his aisel knew his
aquinus and AUST anyway I I happen to
study the prince over the summer and it
will blow your mind and you know what
the more you read it the more you
realize how much the left play plays by
the rules of makavelli wow if the right
played by the rules of makavelli as much
as the left we would win and I don't
just mean the ends justify the means I
mean how to use political power how to
use political power and you use that
term gangster I got to tell you
makavelli laid out that kind of Playbook
Trump I don't know if he's ever read the
prince or not maybe back in college or
whatever but probably didn't but he uh
he plays that out Nico yeah niio M he
started the enlightenment so he uh the
be he was the first guy to ever say wait
hold on we have all these old books and
all these old writings why don't we just
cast that aside and get what we want and
that was by the way medich family one of
the only families that kept their wealth
for five six seven generations crazy
vanderbel couldn't do it you know some
of these other families couldn't do it
michi's been going for quite a long time
Florence which video is this this is a
he cried like a baby oh I love this okay
go and play this I used to go to sleep
at night I don't know if this is the
right one actually the leader of the
Taliban you would obliterate him if he
dared not to follow every dotted ey
cross T comma period Abdul I did had a
conversation had a number of
conversations didn't you at one point
tell him I know exactly where you are
and give him the exact coordinates where
he was oh I sent him a picture of his
house he said but why but why do you
send me a picture why is the music so
loud fig that one out you told the I
send a picture of his house that's it's
very Mach of valiant but and then think
about this though Charlie this is the
the amount of hate that they had for
there one guy remember when he did kill
solomani you know what CNN was calling
uh Solani he's a freedom fight like they
they were almost feeling bad and they
Pelosi and all them went after him for
killing a terrorist that's how much
Trump derangement syndrome it's embedded
in people like that it's embedd in
people like stmi and it's bro it's past
Trump it's the it's the it's what they
stand for yes is enough is enough that
that strength that uh strength through
peace like we that's how we have to roll
nobody respects us peace to strength
everything is going to and every I
I I tired of this everybody we're Tippy
toeing it's time that we start saying We
Told You So we told you so about coid we
told you so about the Border we told you
that BLM was a scam that they were
trying to screw all of us over how many
times are weas going to go no and brush
it away we told you we woke tried to
wake your asses up and now you got him
writing a soliloquy nobody gives a
about dairo anymore bro go go make a
movie we don't have time to read that
he's just sitt around Pat New York just
hating Trump we have more to worry
about uh than than somebody worried
about Trump bro like it just drives me
nuts that when I when I hear din it's
personal it's personal it's personal
Trump got together with a girl he was
something it's got to be something you
cannot you cannot there's something that
is so personal for him to have that kind
of hate towards Trump I think I think
you because you have spent so much time
with the gangsters and Michael and Sammy
and a lot of our friends you bring up a
great point pbd and I and to any of my
leftists or people on the liberal
friends I totally understand why it
would be very easy to not like Trump at
face value I get it but the the whole do
you want a strong leader running the mob
the country what have you or do you want
a weak leader that nobody respects and
that's where you start to see some of
the horribleness that happens over there
and to your point who are the gangsters
that are funding Biden or whoever the
non- gangster president than it is
that's a very important point I just
don't want to just kind of gloss over
that it is it is something that is you
when you peel back the layers of who's
funding Biden who's putting these things
together I I totally understand why why
that makes a lot by the way you know
this this next debate that's coming up
the Republican debate November right
it's going to be Miami the one that's
going to be
here you're going to be able to filter
out all the candidates very quickly very
true I I think it's going to be like a a
pure filtering system what did he just
say wait what did she just say are you
are you serious about okay that one's
gone this one's gone I know exactly
where he's at I know exactly where he's
at and I know exactly where she's at
okay cool here we go oh yeah I think
this is going to be the fastest
filtering system not that they're going
to be doing anything with presidency I'm
not even talking about presidency but
for you to know like Administration job
future who's Israel Palestine because
you know Nikki Haley's going to be up
there right off the rip talking about B
Iran why do you say that this one's
going to more of a filtering one because
nothing happened in uh California was a
show why Miami though because now
you have like when's the last time
something like this happened in Israel
50 years ago I mean this is like the
biggest catastrophic event they've had
since the Holocaust you know some are
saying okay most Jews dead this is this
is this is not like you know people are
worried about Jews you know in a sense
of you know how big the population it's
15 million people you you're not talking
about 300 million Jews worldwide you're
not talking about 700 million Jews
worldwide the world's jewy yeah you're
not talking bless you're not talking
about a big number don't get me
wrong the criticism and look at the
power they have the influence they have
the Hollywood and all this stuff Fair we
can have that conversation no problem
but they're going to have to make their
case and the argument and I'm so curious
know how how they're going to make the
case obviously vivec was on uh Tucker
yeah this last week and and Tucker said
you know Nikki Haley sounds like a child
right and then vivec tried to give like
protect her a little bit and say I don't
know about child but I don't you know
agree with what you know he's got to say
or what she's got to say it's going to
be interesting I think it's going to be
a great field Turing system and and by
the way let me transition to a complete
different story um have you followed
what's going on with Aaron Rogers and
Kelsey and the fer thing where ESPN is
brick saying what the hell is
going let me read this story to you ESPN
Under Fire after Aaron Rogers challenges
Travis Kelce to vaccine debate onet work
this is with Pat McAfee there saying
love mcafe is
hilarious I used to not like him now I
have mad respect that that that guy
is
espb Rogers Rogers playfully referred to
Kelsey as Mr fizer and Kelsey responded
with humor coining the feud as Mr fizer
versus the Johnson and Johnson family uh
the controversy escalated when Rogers
during his appearance on the Pat McAfee
show challenged Kelsey to a vaccine
debate he suggested RFK as his partner
and Anthony fouchy for Kelsey ESPN's NFL
Insider Adam Schaefer shared a clip
describing as the potential next Great
American debate the decision by ESPN to
highlight this debate which is rooted
and widely debunked vaccine related
theories this is a mediaite story
triggered strong uh reactions with
gambling reporter Dustin Galer stating
ESPN should be embarrassed for airing
this nonsense yeah a debate is
embarrassing you know someone should
find find out how much does the Walt
Disney Corporation receive from fizer
and advertising every single year that's
a great question I don't I don't know if
that's I I watch I watch too much
football right I love I it's my one
Indulgence I know it's woke I know I
don't care I just love it it's a
beautiful sport it's uniquely American
do we have his audio of what Rogers said
on by the way this this is his media
Outlet mean like Rogers goes to that's
AJ Hawk show before he plays this TR
let's not forget Aaron Rogers Pat has a
chip on his shoulder remember when he
didn't want to get the vaccine they
shamed him they called him a denier they
dude everybody went after him like uh
Novak jokovic and made and that's why I
do I think was brilliant when he won the
open God God bless him and good for him
but bro good for him because think about
it the the who's the Travis Kelce God
forbid all his young following
especially now with what's her face uh
the swifties and now football's up and
telling people to get the vaccine if God
forbid one of these 18-year-old boys
that follows you Travis gets it and gets
myo carditis are you paying for it his
hospital bills are you no no Adam are
you going to take care of him no you're
not so to push this drug that's still
freaking new on kids is ridiculous so I
mean I love this because this is him
getting them back for the that they
put on good point I mean it wasn't too
long ago two years ago he you know did a
interview and he said he was immunized
yeah exactly imun so what does that mean
I'm just immunized all right and then
obviously he's got some time on his
hands with this Achilles injury but do
we have that audio I mean listen
you know Mr fizer said he didn't think
he'd be in a vax war with me didn't
think he'd be in a VX war with me this
ain't a war homie this is just
conversation but if you want to have
some sort of duel Pat
debate have be on the podcast come on
the show let's have
conversation pass it up let's do it like
uh like in the John Wick four right so
we both have a second right for somebody
to help us out I'm going to take my man
RFK Jr
okay okay as an independent hell yeah
right and he can have you know Tony
fouchy or some other pharmac and we
wondering am I gonna keep this job or
not I'm happy we got that sorted thought
for sure you're done withan but
obviously wouldn't you watch that
wouldn't you watch uh it would never
happen I I know but I would payper viiew
for that Charlie you wouldn't pay to see
that oh it would let me ask you a
question let me ask a question how much
money would you have to pay Anthony
fouchy to do a three-hour debate long
form podcast 10 million bucks he's not
he's not no I actually I actually am
asking you a real question with who what
is the dollar amount for Anthony fouchy
to agree on a three-hour debate for
against RFK thre hour what how much
money would he would he want and
realistically I I don't think he would
do it but 10 million bucks he's not I'm
telling you right now I'll pay the 10
million I know I I will pay 10 on record
right now I'll pay fouchy 10 million
bucks 3 hours live podcast with RFK and
he still won't do it I'm telling you
right now I'll pay 10 million bucks and
he still won't do it he still will not
do it because he'll get exposed are you
kidding me y because he's he's not
there's no way this guy's going to do
something like that do you know what RFK
would do with him with all the facts and
everything he still would he wrote the
book about him that's right he knows
about him if there's a guy he would
never do it with is with RFK it would
never happen never he would be the type
of guy that would come out and say of
course I would do it this isn't about
money this is about People's Health and
there's no way in the world this makes
any sense to sit down and talk to an RFK
like this I'm I'm willing to tell you
put the number at 100 million I was just
going to say what if we ra what if
everybody raised he wouldn't do 100
million why do you think he won't do it
go to jail after actually ask the
question why do you think he won't do it
why he won't cuz he'll be he'll be
exposed for everything that he did he
can go to jail because he can't do it
yeah the people of power will never let
him do it are you kidding me he's he
won't get permission to do it he works
for these big farmer guys right you can
pay him a 100 million they're going to
call him and say dude you're yeah go
ahead and do it and see what we do to
your legacy of NIH and everything that
we have on you go ahead and do it go
ahead go ahead and do that see what
happens to you he wouldn't do it for 100
so crazy cuz you're so right he wouldn't
do it for a 100 million bucks big Pharma
would never allow him to do it what if
he said I'll do it P I'll take the 100
million but you guys have to protect me
like they're going to come after me stop
it no they would he's done they would
they do the exact opposite of protect
him they would say all right listen guy
here's here's x amount of money I would
10 million I would do 10 million I would
run out the Miami Heat arena okay I
would bring RFK I would sell 20,000
tickets I would do it live I would bring
a moderator from the left to ask
questions moderator from the right to
ask questions I'm the one that's going
to be
I'm the I'm the one in the middle I'm
the main moderator but I bring guys so
you can ask RFK whatever questions you
want as well no problem and somebody on
the side can ask uh uh uh uh fouchy any
questions they want outside of what RFK
would ask it would become a big event
it'd be an event the world would watch
wow and he would still not do it for 10
million bucks I guarantee you just to
add to that because uh Charlie mentioned
you know what Disney would do on this
let's not forget Disney owns ABC which
owns ESPN and the whole conglomerate
right there that's why you're bringing
this up but the bigger thing is and you
brought this up on the um the event that
you did with Tim p and Matt Gates which
was awesome and James o'keef and you
were railing against how much money uh
goes to from Big Pharma to Legacy Media
to the CNN's of the world to the foxes
of the world cable news outlets of the
world and that you were harping on this
is something that you that you've been
studying pretty closely what would
happen if they stopped taking big farm
of money to these major cable Outlets
you know what would happen no I mean it
it it makes up their whole bottom line
right I mean again I watch a lot of
football every other commercial is the
Travis Kelce commercial it it is it is
running nonstop have that commercial you
can do two things at once it's pathetic
get a flu shot and the vaccine yeah and
I I see it on ESPN property probably 10
times every Saturday for college
football Rob we don't need to show it we
don't we don't need to and those are
$50,000 you know throw spots so that's
they're spending millions of dollars
every day on that ad with ESPN yeah and
it's crazy Charlie you see the world
economic forum lady we rob we covered it
last week she's literally they're not
even hiding anymore you know what she
said we tried to vaccinate the planet
didn't work she's like we tried to you
know people can't grasp climate change
now they're like yeah let's mess with
the water they're they're just
Relentless they're trying to they're
trying to get rid of all these freaking
vaccines dude it's disgusting let's talk
about Steve scalise and what's going on
there so story Wall Street Journal page
13 if you want to go to it um this is
this is speak of the house this is all
the mess that's what's going on with
himself Jim Jordan okay here we go Wall
Street Journal October 10 Steve scales
Jim Jordan makes pitches for house
Speaker as GOP Warriors grow House
Majority Leader Steve scalise Republican
and representative Jim Jordan Ohio
outlined their Visions during a closed
door candidate form lawmakers discuss
priorities including reigning in $33
trillion national debt according to one
participant some lawmakers Express
uncertainty about either candidate
securing the necessary 217 votes with
represent majority uh jerie Taylor green
uh saying I don't think anybody has 217
a potential rule change could require
repeated votes until the winning
candidate gains Garners 217 votes votes
according to representa chip Roy and Mar
emodi uh sought commitments from
candidates emphasizing support for
moving a bill to transfer Federal lands
to Nevada so Charlie what's going on
here is is there going to be a decision
being made yeah there there will be um
if scales becomes speaker I think that's
a downg from McCarthy to be honest I
mean I think scal is a sweet guy I mean
a Democrat tried to murder him right so
I mean and he's also battling cancer
that was during the whole softball game
in DC was that yeah and he's also
battling cancer right now so it's not
personal but let me just introduce you
know a part of this that people are
afraid to mention okay um you physically
cannot do the job of speaker of the
house and travel 300 days and raise $300
million from now to next November in my
personal opinion and also fight cancer
that's a big thing and that sounds you
know kind of nasty or unfair but that
needs to be factored in you have to
understand there's Congressional
elections every two years right Pat you
know what it's like to travel 300 days a
year it destroys your body right I
traveled 3,000 days in the last decade
and it's not easy right my back is all
screwed up you don't imagine you're the
speaker of the house you have a
legislative agenda you're constantly
dealing with a very very slim majority
you have to travel the country to go
raise 300 million bucks okay minimum
because Hakeem Jeff is building that war
chest building that war chest building
that war chest you have to recruit
candidates keep candidates in you're
about to see a whole bunch of
retirements come up right that's a bad
sign meaning a bunch of Republicans
saying I'm retiring that means you have
to find a new candidate so the speaker
is in charge of a lot of that stuff at
the nrcc and I mean I I know it's if if
you're battling blood cancer man that's
tough to do that right I think that puts
us at a significant disadvantage plus
he's also way too moderate for my liking
Jim Jordan would have been a big upgrade
right um but Steve scales backed Liz
Cheney in his in the primary in Wyoming
um he's really bad on Ukraine in my
opinion uh again nice person terrible
what he's been through but I I think
this would be a downgrade if it becomes
so why why why didn't Jim get it though
well it's not not we don't know yet it's
still I know but but there was one time
we because he's too conservative yeah
there's 150 people in the house
Republican caucus that are incredibly
moderate right very very moderate they
you you get like a a bad impression
because the people that go on television
Ana Paulina Luna you know Matt Gates
they they actually don't make up a
majority of the Republican conference
you know a majority of the Republican
conference never goes on TV they kind of
keep their head down they like the title
Congressman but they're very moderate
they're transactional Republican regime
politicians right they kind of just vote
for what how they're told they do what
leadership tells them I don't even know
I mean I know a lot about politics I
don't know like a hundred of these guys
right they're kind of just in the
background but they they are they are
very very mad that McCarthy is no longer
speaker and so they're going to hold the
line and they're like we're getting a
more moderate speaker going to be in
charge and this is them exacting revenge
on bigs and Rosen Dale and you know Roy
and those guys that so do you think Matt
Gates could move when he pushed McCarthy
out well I I first of all I I was asked
him at the time I said what is the plan
and he said that anyone is better than
Kevin McCarthy I said that's not true
okay that I don't I don't agree with
that but I said Matt you'll either be
proven right or be proven wrong right if
you get a more conservative speaker
someone that has I think Jim Jordan by
the way would be amazing at raising the
money he's you know former uh you know
really college level wrestler wrestling
coach like he has great physical stamina
like he could really go toe-to-toe with
Jeff on the fundraising tour and the
travel circuit like all that stuff that
sometimes can really wear you down to
Kevin McCarthy's credit he took that
very seriously he traveled like a crazy
person just to be able to you know
handle everything but um yeah I mean
like Jordan should be the guy uh and
it's not over yet but it doesn't look
very good for him would would you
nominate Jordan I didn't even know about
Steve scal having blood cancer as we
speak how is that even a consideration
melanoma or something can you fact check
me on that melanoma skin cancer but if
it's blood cancer it's probably leukemia
is probably what it is either but either
way he's dealing with cancer right now
not exactly uh advantageous I wasn't
that far off myom I'm sorry my okay yeah
my so if you because it sounds like
you've had some conversations with Matt
Gates and you had some agreements and
disagreements who would you want to see
nominated because they're now they're
talking about nominating Trump which
would literally flip crazy Nancy on her
uh flip her grave so to speak Theo would
kill him I I I think Jim Jordan would be
great I mean I think Jim Jordan's super
conservative I've known Jim for years um
he would do a terrific job honestly we
need to just get the speaker position
filled we have such a slim majority
every day we're just burning time we
have a continuing resolution coming up
that's exactly what Democrats W by no I
mean they're they're loving this right
we have a wide open border we have not
done anything to reign in Jack Smith
we've done nothing to materially
actually find out where the Ukraine
money is going the administrative state
is out of control like the top
priorities for me none of them are
getting done if we don't have a speaker
right and if Steve scales makes some
commitments and he proves me wrong great
I mean I'm not going to like you know
really oppose him at this point we have
such a slim majority at this point are
we going to keep the house in January
2025 and honestly the odds are not good
the odds are not good for Republicans to
keep the house but to be clear Charlie
it sounds like you would have been cool
with McCarthy staying speaker yeah
versus scalise yeah and I got I mean
it's well known I I'm I get along with
Kevin I have for years I mean he has I
think he made a miscalculation on the
continuing resolution I wish he would
have held the line and shutting on the
government I think would have been
appropriate to be perfectly honest
because it's actually not a shutdown
it's more like a pause we are a deor
nation $2 trillion deficit that's your
annual burn unsustainable in my opinion
it should have been the Republican's big
Last Stand and instead you know he did a
punt and he punted 45 days he lost the
speakership as a result of it we we are
un we are destroying the dollar right
our deficit spending is shredding the
dollar we don't have a border these are
these we're in a crisis and I wish the
Republicans would have held the line a
lot better with that last CR how much of
this with Matt Gates because we were
just with him uh was personal a lot 90%
90 95% so this wasn't even about the
countries like at the end of the day
Matt Gates and I'm not saying that it's
not about America this is a personal
issue with M I'm speculating but it
seemed to be hyper personal wow yeah it
seemed kind of like how dairo and Trump
have a thing Gates and McCarthy got a
thing didn't they have a few had
something in 2021 something happened
between them and there's something about
an Ethics investigation too that
McCarthy didn't drop and yeah then
allegedly Gates was accusing McCarthy of
hiring people to go after him online so
this thing was just bubbling up right of
course before McCarthy became the
speaker of the house there was a 15 vote
process which was awfully humiliating
for McCarthy right of course and there
was literally almost a physical
altercation between Gates and another
congressman and this was a personal
issue and I'm friends with Matt and I
told Matt I said Matt you're the member
of Congress you know you're betting big
man you're going all in Texas Holden
this could end up being really good if
we get scalise it at the best it's a
wash that we now lost a couple weeks and
we got humiliated and it looks like a
Chinese fire drill and at the worst we
get somebody who isn't as conservative
who does not even have in my personal
opinion the time let's just forget like
the physical part if you're fighting
cancer man the time alone is going to
distract you from what is necessary for
us to beat the Democrats and I say that
from a compassionate standpoint I want
him to go beat cancer right yeah I it's
just he's going to have he's going to
have a lot on his plate I mean if you're
dealing with cancer I feel I mean
respect deal with that that automatic
disqualifier oh my God can you imagine
like the stress and everything that adds
on to it can't why why is he the leading
candidate who who because McCarthy's
running a shadow campaign to get him
because he he's very close to McCarthy
so think about it McCarthy steps down he
still wants the power he wants the power
behind the throne right he he was the
one that recruited 200 you know 180 of
the candidates that make up the majority
right he's the one that busted his tail
and McCarthy want to wants to exact
revenge on those guys that got rid of
him and so McCarthy's not going away
what do you think would want to do to
get Matt Gates um on a personal level or
even on a political level what would
McCarthy want to see happen to Gates I
mean I I don't I can't speak for Kevin
in that way but it's going to get really
nasty I mean there he's already running
McCarthy's pack is already running some
of the nastiest ads I've ever seen
against those eight people what's
McCarthy's relationship with Trump today
um they've always gotten along but uh I
think Kevin has disappointed Trump
didn't bail him out Trump could have
bailed him out yeah so Trump could have
either come to DC or tweeted and said
guys stop it Kevin's our guy don't do
this Trump could have saved Kevin's
speakership last question on this for me
so I think Kevin's a little sour does
all this House of Representative Saga
help or hurt the Democrats helps the
Democrats you kidding me it's not even
close by the way so like why would you
do this then to help the other party the
argument was and I understand this
argument I really do that we have zero
legis ative winds while the country is
legitimately financially collapsing that
is not an exaggeration we are destroying
the dollar we're borrowing money we
don't have and Republicans were like you
know what when are we going to fight we
got screwed on the debt ceiling we got
screwed on the budget and we got screwed
on continuing resolution I kind of get
that simp sentent I really do that would
have been probably strategically smarter
if you don't have a four- seat majority
okay that's one of the the smallest
majorities in American history right and
again I keep on going going after this
you have to you have to always look at
and what I'm doing is increasing or
decreasing the chances that we keep the
house in the next session that's not the
most important thing but it's important
and it's significantly decreased Hakeem
Jeff's donations have gone up Democrats
are recruiting really exciting good
candidates Republican enthusiasm is down
in the House of Representatives so we
got a serious problem yeah so it's
either this is a hail Mar pass either
you score some crazy touchdown in the
end uh Hail Mary style or you get or you
turn the ball over the other team gets
it at the very to get offsetting
penalties you're like well that was a
waste of time right I mean and so that
that's the best case scenario here's
your college Dame day that you're all
about I could use football analogies all
day long right but no I mean what I will
say though is that House Republicans
need to start fulfilling the Mandate
that their voters gave them and the
three big priorities is you have to get
this Ukraine funding under control I
think you have to cut it completely and
get rid of it you have to get Jack Smith
and the doj have some sort of check and
balance and the border right and if I
had to add a fourth which is can you
please cut spending guys MH $2 trillion
deficit is unsustainable we are a de
Nation we we are destroying our
purchasing power it is harder than ever
to buy a home inflation is a silent tax
and a silent killer for working people
it disincentivizes saving and inflation
is a direct correlat to how much money
Washington DC
spends by the way let's talk about
something important if you can pull the
Su it's which is probably the most
important issue taking place in the
country today uh uh uh you can pull it
up
deeply concerning specifically for those
who live in the state of California
Skittles yeah if you can pull this up we
have we have to bring attention to this
catastropic so California becomes the
first state what to ban Skittles no this
has got to be a Babylon V article and
and 12,000 no
additional by the way okay what is
puberty that pu Instagram you know it's
for real watch who retweets it at the
top go see who retweets it at the top
Mario Lopez say by the bill oh my God
they're okay so crime is is this real
for we're going to look this up we're
going to look this up crime is through
the roof Rob go back to the tweet I
don't believe it go back to crime is
through the roof worst struck epidemic
ever homelessness at an all-time high in
California let's focus on Skittles okay
by the way they responded back to it and
there's a story that says um uh you've
seen this or no no no I haven't seen it
yeah they respond back to it
and they said new just signed the
California Skittles ban into a law uh
USA Today new California law won't ban
Skittles but could change food additives
okay USA Today response so it is a back
and forth It's so funny though yeah
Governor new on Saturday sign it's
almost believable yeah no but by the way
no no hang on one second because it is
true though this is the part that the
fact that you're thinking this is a
babon be story removing four makes me
want to share this even more share the
USA today's story that I just texted you
that at least this one's going to give
it so and then if you go a little lower
I'll just read it for him to see it
second paragraph I just texted it to you
the article reads A bill that became
known as the Skittles ban is now
California law this ISS USA Today okay
so check this out a bill that became
known okay zoom out a little bit more no
a little bit more there you go and then
zoom in a bill that became known can you
show what the source is USA Today a bill
that became known as the Skittles ban is
now California law here's what it does
Governor nsam on Saturday signed a law
misleading known as the Skittles ban
which will prohibit the manufactur and
sale of four chemicals used in as many
as 12,000 food products okay go a little
lower uh on the second paragraph
Governor Nome on Saturday sign Miss
leading law know
of brominated vegetable oil potassium
bromate and a couple other things red D
3 the four chemicals are used in as many
as 12,000 products across the country
despite uh never having been approved
for consumption by the Food and Drug
Administration according to an
environmental working group Advocates
have long expressed concerns about the
potential health problems that can be
caused by eating these products can you
imagine if people leave California for
Banning Skittles but not for forcing Co
vaccine can you imagine can you imagine
obviously when I'm saying Co vaccine
Force they almost did and and Mario
Lopez I want to finish up his tweet can
you go back to the tweet on what he said
go up there yeah zoom out uh uh there
you go zoom in a little bit at the top
crime is through the roof worst epidemic
ever homelessness at an altime high but
let's focus on Skittles I'm shocked that
he by the way he's in with that he is
like in the in right he's in the In
Crowd for him to go against you know who
else has been saying stuff like this he
has uh Mark Wahlberg has Mark Wahlberg's
turning yeah he's Mark Wahlberg has he
moved to Nevada he's there he's fully
there by the way he's knocking on the
door Chris Pratt has been there for a
while okay so more and more people are
starting to kind of say is a little
let me I'm not good with this
year right and Mario Lopez who we've had
at uh same event you were at in Vegas uh
Wahlberg we know about Chris Pratt we
know about but Mario Lopez I mean that
he's the guy that you've go in any hotel
ever he's the guy that doing the whole
movie I think Mario was on Candace Owens
like a year and a half ago something
like that right and he got in trouble
for something he does the uh the the
movie the movie guide stuff yeah exactly
but I challenge you guys out there to
find me one jenz Hollywood actor find me
one gen Z so that's 25 and under who's
center right find me one that you can
name I I can't think of one I mean you
you put it in the comments but if you're
not in that Hollywood Elite woke left
crowd mob some may call it uh you're
cancelled so you know when you have an
established career like Mark Wahlberg or
even Chris Pratt and you sort of you're
you're sort of Mark Wahlberg is an OG
though I'm going to no is it I'm going
to what was this don't call her a come
which one I've here
call Good Vibration VI let's get
vibrations he was a Calin Klein model I
mean the movie he played fear oh my God
he banging his gang oh that was a great
way before Wolf of Wall Street did he
got it from him he did basketball what's
crazy is the most ironic thing about
these Skittles thing if you if
California was a candy it would be
Skittles 1,000% with the LGBT and W and
the Dei ESG and everything that's going
on dare you I love Skittles okay
Starburst Skittles you're talking my
language po California banning Skittles
I was actually thinking about going back
to California moving there but this the
thing about this though this is going to
be great for you know who when the
santis debates him follows the santis I
look right
up and he goes like this as he leaves he
should go you like some Skittles Taste
the rainbow like I would screw with him
every moment i' be like taste the
somebody would how shame on you for
eliminating the rainbow in the state of
California shame on you guess what it's
the rainbow yeah just troll him the
whole time the whole time by the way
your thoughts on this debate with des
santis and Nome is it is it like uh I've
never heard of this happening before
one's running for president one's not
what do you think well first I mean Nome
is slick he he he's he's got a talent
and I'm just I'm just gonna be honest
like I game knows game right and that
guy can play um he says he fell for it
he fell for it yeah remember when he
said that about yeah and I mean he goes
on conservative media and he can play I
don't think he'd surviv the pbd podcast
but he he he prays on conservative media
that he has an open invitation yes and I
mean same on my show anytime Gavin
Newsome can come on the show so um as
from from presidential standpoint I mean
Trump's going to be the nominee so it's
kind of just a waste of time I do think
it's actually healthy to have a
conversation though and this is why I
wish to santis would just right now see
where he's at drop out become a great
governor and reassert that he's been a
great governor and continue to be I'll
say nothing but positive things but the
the national conversation is there are
really two Americas being built right
now and California is a hell hole it's a
dystopian nightmare if you have money
you can maybe Escape it but it is a hell
hole on the streets drugs homelessness
vagrancy mutilation of children quality
of standards of Education businesses
taxes and Florida is a completely
different environment and Patrick I was
in California last week just from an
energy standpoint Like A vibe and an
attitude the people in California are
just heavy and dark and just it's not
the spirit I come that's usually New
York's thing guys no but I mean it it's
not it's not the California energy that
I'm used to I come here in Florida and
boy things are happening man right it
has a buzz to it Florida would love to
have you by the way well thank you I I
need to save Arizona just for the record
you want me to save Arizona if Arizona
is not saved there's no Republic so you
want you want Charlie Kirk in Arizona
Charlie you you you're sort of echoing
what pbd has been saying saying for
weeks now if not months that after
railing on uh Nome for years during Co
called him U-Haul employee of the year
we've saw that you know U-Haul to go to
California is like $1,000 to get the
hell out of California it's like
$5,000 but he's slick he's skilled what
is it about him that people in
California recognize oh I hate that guy
but goes on conservative media and he
dominates well yeah first of part of it
is you you the right word dominant part
of this is just he's so cocky that he
just kind of intimidates the host and
talks over him and he just tries to act
more Alpha that's why he would not do
well with Patrick B David right that
that dog would not hunt around here
right um and because he he would avoid
that Tucker Carlson would obliterate him
right would you agree Patrick it would
it would it would be sport right yeah it
would be a spectacle and it it would be
just out of control so but you're saying
Hannity is a lightweight no I'm not
saying that I'm saying Hannity is used
to old cable television and not new age
internet livetime back and forth type
debate style it's not Sean's a friend
and I'm not accusing Shawn saying Shawn
is treating Gavin Nome like a 1990s
cable guest where you kind of both state
your point and you say oh this nice
having you thanks you know Mr Colmes
right Hannity and Colmes Gavin Newsome
plays the new age viral Tik Tock debate
I'm gonna one up you I'm going to you
know what I'm saying like I'm going to
get that 30 second boom boom put it on
social it's like oh he owned him yeah I
kind of in that world right that's right
you're definitely one of those got yeah
of course you got a few billion views of
that yeah we have a couple billi exactly
we we helped create that genre Shapiro
Welsh Candace and I we are kind of some
of the Pioneers there so I see new I'm
like either he gets it intuitively
spends a lot of time on social or he has
a team that's kind of coached him so
it's not a knock on Hannity but um yeah
Ronda santis better treat this kind of
in that format this is not a policy
debate okay it g gab is going to lie
right so one of the rules of marxist is
show don't tell okay so here's what
here's how DeSantis should handle
because I'm going to be cheering for Dan
santis right G Dan santis will say you
know uh Governor Newsome someone's
leaving your state every eight minutes
and Gavin new like no no that's not true
in fact we have all these great and so
he has to literally Gavin Newsome has to
New York Times see Gavin Newsome
someone's leaving every eight minutes
you have to show fact check fact Che
real real time you know you know the
thing that Trump did when he's
like marxists hate it when you show
telling is not enough cuz is a lie yeah
because like when Trump brought the four
women that accused Clinton of sexual
assault it was the most mindblowing
thing all of a sudden to a presidential
debate Trump turned into Jerry Springer
Show the most insane thing I've ever
seen but he showed the world if you
remember what Clinton looked like in
that debate Hillary was freaked out
Hillary was like is really bad what
Trump said uh let's talk about uh
bombing Russia yeah exactly and it was
just like wait all of a sudden it was
over and so for I actually like the idea
that the debate is happening the
presidential implications are silly but
the debate of you can have a different
country based on how States operate is
very interesting Florida has
unbelievable outcomes right in education
and B you guys I don't have to you know
your audience knows it too keep it a
secret here though Charlie nobody knew
about Florida and Miami until uh you
guys start show up but I will say if if
if if Nim ties Andor wins that debate it
would be a tragedy it' be because the
facts are so not on his side do you
agree Patrick
it's like defending the Soviet Union but
give me the argument what does he have
to win what does he have to gain what
does the Sanz have to gain well he's
he's down 50 points with Trump it's not
a bad IDE he's trying to get some sort
of visibility right he's trying to get
some sort of credibility so um I I'm not
I'm not overly impressed right now with
desantis's ability to play ball with
this kind of game right where DeSantis
is like come do the speech do great
policy move on now Trump vome woo like
Trump would just you know that Trump is
built in that kind he kind of created
that kind of you know you'd be in jail
and you know boom and OB Bama him and
this and that and like the one liners
he's just like oh he's the that you want
to talk about gangster Pat you talked
earlier Trump trump bringing the rape
victims to that that is gangsters by the
way him him when Hillary goes It's
awfully good that you know Trump isn't
in charge of the laws in this country
and he goes yeah cuz you'd be in jail
that is a gangster fighter and by way if
I was Nome to go further with the
skittle thing if I was the santis I
would cuz you know he sits there and
they're going to be face to face I would
fill up those high heel cowboy boots
with Skittles at the end and honestly if
I was to santis I would get nasty first
and I I would I would go low this guy's
a bad dude you say you know what Gavin
what where you ever been in charge where
it's not hell San Francisco is a hell
hole you never take responsibility for
anything if you believe in San Francisco
so much will you walk at 3:00 a.m. from
Fisherman's Worth to the Trans America
building without a bodyguard yes or no
Gavin Newsome no show me show me that
you would walk from Fisherman's Warf and
Gavin would no no you're Phil no no no
you wouldn't better question would you
let your son would you let your son at
3:00 a.m. in San Francisco guess what 30
years ago the answer of course one of
the safest cities in the planet now they
get mugged you get kidnapped right you
get defecated by some crazy person
that's how you have to play that game
with Gavin aggression put him on defense
because he plays ball man like I I'm
just being honest gamer I I I I think
he's one I respect his game respect
he he and I'll be honest like the fact
he showed up at the Republican debate
like that dude has stoned like I'm I'm
not going to lie right like I mean I you
got you go to the Reagan Library like
anyone can come up and film a question
you I was like man that's like respect
is this the sandis is Hail Mary to use
that term again the sandis is not going
be the nominated the Hail Mary he he's
down 56 nothing with like 30 seconds
left on the clock sure it's like all
like moral points at this point how he
still fund at this point I think he just
brought in another $20 million whatever
the number was I'm are people still mov
enti to Iowa million Consultants can be
very persuasive and also a lot of these
donors they don't live in the Grassroots
like I do like I I give hundreds of
speeches a year okay I get I can read an
audience really well who are you voting
for Trump I'm like whoa and then you see
it in the polls and you confirm it and
it's across the board the polls don't
matter according to santis Charlie well
okay I mean then show me one when you're
within 10 points right I mean and not
just polls how about audience size like
social media chatter show me one metric
how about this small dollar donations
Trump raised $30 million to santis
raised like five or six you can fact
check me on it right in his last quarter
it's the small dollar donor equal
support Bernie Sanders actually showed
us this right everyone's like oh Bernie
isn't real and I was like man the dude
has like a million donors he's going to
give Hillary a run for her money and he
was right right if you have people that
give you 10 bucks that's like basically
a thousand votes right and it was it was
right like Bernie Sanders played against
him so no but Gavin here's the thing
with Gavin Gavin is a cocky SOB he is a
cocky got cocky dude he a trump of the
left minus the money and the the he has
he isia he's the guy that walks around
with his nose up in the air and one of
these days he's gonna get crossed over
by someone who knows the game better
than him right that he's going to get
punched in the mouth metaphorically by a
pbd or a Tucker or a Walsh or a Shapiro
or someone like me cuz there's only so
much ball you could play and Icarus is
going to fly too close to the one could
argue that that Gavin Nome is the
definition of fake news he's almost like
the emperor has no clothes on he's
running around with this uh holier than
thou methodology ideology I'll show up
anywhere yes but under the cloak it's
homelessness crime nakedness the only I
mean this is the truth and I I've
actually thought deeply about this the
only reason California is not like
legitimately a third world country it's
because of the weather at this point and
I there is nothing left except the
weather I I talked to people in
California like okay so you got like
vagrancy everywhere you got highest
taxes regulation California Franchise
Tax Board the schools are a mess why
well Charlie have you ever walked at 67
degrees in the morning in Thousand
California so crazy but you're so right
and it's awfully persuasive I got to be
honest like if you walk up to those you
know what I'm talking about that do mist
and kind of the Marine layer that sets
in and it's kind of like that Aspen feel
you're like yeah maybe I don't care
maybe I don't care if the homeless guy
but then you have the guy that's like
yeah I would love to do that but gas
costs $7 a gallon and I can't even make
it on the other side of what I'm saying
though is it would be so much worse
right it's like it's almost California
is a test case of how bad can you make a
civilization with like Pleasant mornings
and evenings for me they cross the line
with Skittles it's over once you get
that it's done done I'm not doing this
video is not an exaggeration it's just
it's look like that looks like a
different country no is that Hollywood
pet where is that that that's in La that
that video that video is from a couple
years ago but it hasn't was it hasn't
gotten better I genuinely left right
like that that right there under under
the under the uh bridges in Burbank like
Laurel Canyon that's ex it was that's
your old house right there that's my old
apartment right there that that tent is
actually my apartment but yeah it's uh
it's getting really really bad but you
nailed it bro people are like dude the
traffic everything is like yeah but the
weather nice there's no hum surfing this
morning and I'm going skiing in the
afternoon yeah there's no humidity let's
go by the way you know I think about
Trump I don't know if he drives a car or
not when's the last time he
drove the last car I saw him the other
day for about an hour and a half we
didn't talk about that but you know he
talks openly about how he misses driving
he used to love D yeah pbd I figured it
out this is my kind of guy Donald Trump
doesn't drive everywhere that's my guy
yeah no no no that's right exactly no I
didn't make it up Donald Trump misses
driving so that's right that's so
freaking funny I can see it though but
by the way I can see him driving and if
he's by himself you know what song I see
him playing thug life for sure by
himself there's a video of him melani
and Baron in the car and they were
playing like Taylor Swift or something
he's playing hit up what what was it I
don't see Taylor Swift no no it's it's
Trump driving in the car with Melania
and Baron and he's playing it's it's
something I don't know I'm saying when
he's by himself it's like all I need in
this life that's the video me and
Melania that's djt driving on the
Brooklyn Bridge this is when what's he
listen to years ago like 10 years
ago
they're listening to not a good look for
Trump to be just jamming out Taylor
Swift but by the way you know what's
weird no he's not controlling the GU
tell you it doesn't is his son or he is
oh Baron is sitting to the right oh
that's Baron Bar's like 79 that's huge
future center of the Dallas Mavericks
under Cuban let's go to the next story
here before we wrap up Rob can you put
up the story with this is Vinnie's Story
one of Vinnie's favorite porn stars uh
Mia Khalifa if you want to kind of a
such a good girl do you want to do you
want to talk about what's going on here
you want me to you want me to break down
what happened with her a such a great
actress I mean I wouldn't call her a
porn star anymore but anyway um the
level of hypocrisy in the story is what
I want you to get Ahad so a former porn
star Mia Khalifa she's basically praised
Hamas if you guys have seen for what
they done over the that tweet is
unbelievable yeah do can someone please
tell the freedom fighters in Palestine
to flip their phones and film
horizontally and Pat you you said this
at the beginning of the podcast and
something like this a crisis of this
magnitude people really show who they
are when the grass is cut system the
snakes the snakes will show so she said
that which is basically saying hey can I
get a better look I want a HD wide
version of children and people getting
murdered and burned to death but you
guys don't want to know the most ironic
part the ironic part about the whole
situation those same Freedom Fighters
that she is praising would chop her head
off if she went to Palestine or she went
anywhere in the Muslim world and just
told Charlie you nailed it she was
having sex with the on top of the
Palestinian and the hijab on let me
explain something what on the flag right
she she was having sex with the dude on
the flag and she had a hijab on I'm
telling you Mia all right there read the
story Isis threat to kill porn star Mia
Khalifa for having sex in a hijab let me
explain and Isis is Hamas it's similar
methodology ideology I I would dare I
dare you to go to any one of these
Muslim nations and talk that don't
even talk that show your face and
they're going to they're going to you're
going to disappear and they're going to
behead you so for her to be praising
what they're doing to innocent people is
absolutely disgusting and bro it's only
a matter of time with someone like this
like by the way she's on their radar
she's not going like there and
especially with what this this Friday
the 13th this guy's calling for a Jihad
she should be hiding more than anybody
well the cognitive dissonance and the
moral Authority from a three time
divorced literal porn star that has sex
on the Palestinian flag to oh my God to
equivocate what's happening right there
like this is only in America well and
where a left feminist Palestinian
sympathizer Hamas
sympathizer can give some equivocation
here how do you break this down well I
mean I said this earlier I mean she's
not alone though I mean the this the
reaction to what happened in Israel has
showed us a disturbing window into how
widespread uh Jew hatred and evil is
it's been it's been a massive massive
wakeup call for some people I mean it
college students Elites that are
cheering it on that are saying it's
terrific what happened um and The
Butchery the savagery and I mean I it's
not hard to understand how the Holocaust
happened and Charlie can that's you a
question bro like the the the squad cuz
you we saw reports somebody from I think
I could I I'm guessing it was Fox they
were going up to what's her name uh not
Elon Omar who's the other one R and
they're just asking her Pat and if it's
okay we'll show it they're just asking
her are you cool with children getting
beheaded I get that you're from
Palestine and I understand that you have
the flag question she born inica she
she's born in America but that's and
some of them were beheaded right in
front of their parents and then their
parents were killed after the parents
had to watch their babies beheaded so
that's what uh and then she has a
Palestinian flag outside of her office
so Hillary's asking her about do you
condone what's happening
watch terrorist have cut off babies
heads and burned children alive do you
support Israel's rights to defend
themselves against morality her
Handler's in front you can't comment
about Hamas terrorist chopping off baby
heads do you
condone what Hamas has done chopping off
babies Heads Burning children alive
raping women in the street look at that
she doesn't give a of course shees
she doesn't care why why would she she
doesn't care she follows her told her to
the elevator I would have gone in with
her being chopped off
look look look what is he going to do
like who is this guy get out of here bro
Congressman why do you have a
Palestinian flag outside your office if
you do not condone whatas terrist done
to Israel yeah because think about this
uh because Adam two things can exist two
things can exist in the same time right
guys you can you can denounce the Mur
what Hamas is doing to the innocent
lives and at the same time still say my
heart goes out to the Palestinians and
the children that are going to be
affected yes I mean it's just it's a
typical political answer terrible what
happened please leave me alone you know
let let let's let tension simmer but
she's silent you know why her
constituency supports this yep and we
don't have time to get into that Patrick
but it's it it has been a big
disappointment how many American Muslims
have have been vocal and support of this
it's been a massive massive
disappointment one thing to consider is
look as a Jew you know I empathize with
the people of Gaza I do like if you're
dealing in this sort of Quasi open air
prison style system with on lockdown I
get it why would you be angry but you
also have to look in the mirror you've
elected Hamas to be over 50% of your
government that is Isis that is
Hezbollah yes that is alqaeda that's who
you've elected now for the other half
that did not elect them I empathize with
you but here's the next question
question you talked about the Allies or
the peace treaties that Israel has
whether it's Jordan whether it's Egypt
what they're working on they have to be
very careful the country right next to
Gaza is what Egypt Egypt so let's focus
on Egypt for a second they don't want
them okay why won't Egypt open up their
borders the Sinai Peninsula is right
there massive desert why won't they open
their borders to help their fellow
brother brother Muslim Brotherhood why
won't they do that cuz they know once
they once they open those borders it's
not just innocent civilians coming
through it is Hamas militant Islamic
terrorist everyone in the region knows
the truth that will be showing up to
Egypt so everyone wants to place blame
on Israel and I get it but let's talk
about your friends Egypt right there
being like no no nothing to see here no
the why not Egypt what Netanyahu should
do if if we had an American president
which we don't we have a traitor in the
overal office is the the next flight
should be to the Middle East and say BB
we give you 4 billion a year don't
invade yet you can do your Rockets or
whatever and you have you bring in the
King Abdullah from Jordan you bring in
whoever's is Ali still running Egypt I
can't keep track you bring in anyone
who's sympathetic and you have a joint
press conference or you first a meeting
with BB and
say Here's here's what we're going to do
we're going to go in and kill Hamas okay
and you let the Arab leaders talk deep
down the Arab leaders actually hate
Hamas like they really do they know it's
aligned with Iran you got to get these
guys in a room you got to have some sort
of a an agreement some sort of here the
problem is again overreaction it's just
going to take one of these actors all it
takes is for Egypt to say our our
neutrality is gone W man that that would
be a disaster it would be a disaster for
the world but that's where American
leadership can come in right Trump would
do that immediately he did the Abraham
Accords Joe Biden has everyone at War
Donald Trump had peace with Israel Saudi
Arabia the UAE he had flights going from
the UAE to Israel still does because
what Donald Trump did and Joe Biden has
babies being butchered in Israel yep
when America's not at least
diplomatically leading you got serious
huge problem gang again as usual it's
always great to have the great Charlie
Kirk here with us thank you guys charlie
keep doing what you're doing your voice
is very important subscribe to the
podcast everybody Charli this is your
third time being here or fourth time I
think this is the third time last time
before you turned 30 happy birthday this
weekend happy birthday a quick shout out
uh if you haven't seen on value tment
pbd uh just did a video called Israel
versus Palestine explained you did it
yesterday it's almost at two million
views right now which is which awesome I
think you did a great job I think you
were fair but you also you know held the
feet to the fire to who actually are the
terrorists here yes so respect to you
for doing that you've gotten a a lot of
praise for doing that respect pbd and by
the way do we have another podcast later
this afternoon we may have another one
gotcha and I'm doing a
sast this evening late night after hours
party time and oo next Wednesday I know
it's your birthday October 18th I'll be
at the Tampa Improv I'm opening for
Vinnie I'm the opener gang have a great
one we'll do this again take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
you